workers are quitting at an absolute
historic pace right now 4.4 million
people quit their job in september world
record congratulations everyone great
job great job 4.4 million people told
their bosses see ya and they walked out
the door all-time high number of job
quitters in one single month that totals
higher 6.46 million for september which
is a slight decline from august you
can't hire a lot of people if there's
lots of people that are all quitting
their jobs 4.4 million quit their jobs
open rolls the labor department in its
job openings and labor turnover survey
said that there were 10.4 million
employment openings well above the 7.6
million people looking for jobs in
september 10.4 million are looking
7.6 million are actually looking for
jobs so 10 million open rolls 7 million
looking for jobs people have been
quitting their jobs all year long
workers ain't taking your nonsense
anymore the workers are leaving real
quick out the door u.s workers left 20
million jobs between may and september
of this year so 4.4 million people quit
their job in september but there was
about 15 and a half million people that
quit their jobs between may
all the way up to the beginning of
september that is 15 higher than the
level from the spring and summer of 2019
pre-pandemic when the job market was the
hottest it had been in almost 50 years
so why exactly are people quitting their
jobs well there's a couple of different
reasons one argument is that they're
leaving their jobs to go and get higher
paying jobs the atlanta fed's wage
growth tracker shows that pay is up 3.6
overall in september from a year ago
with job switchers so the quitters
become switchers seeing a 4.3 increase
news flash inflation is at 6 plus
percent if your pay is up 3.6 you're
getting paid less than you were last
year if you switched your job and you
got a four percent increase in pay
you're getting paid less than you were
last year and so we've got these charts
here first the big challenge the record
number of us job quits shows labor
market churn amid elevated vacancies
absolutely bonkers the number of quits
at the top just can't go higher higher
and higher and higher the number of job
openings still way up there at 10.4
million or so at one point it was close
to 11 million if we then look at the job
market it is on fire too hot to handle
literally the quit rate is still
increasing while the unemployment rate
has fallen all the way down to 4.6 we
live in a country where there are
literally 10.4 million open jobs but
there's 4.6
unemployment absolutely bonkers when you
look at the central bank the central
bank is not fulfilling their mandate
they are supposed to keep a full
employment and also stable prices
there's definitely not stable prices
because inflation's over six percent and
there's definitely not full employment
because we're at 4.6 percent
unemployment we then go ahead and we
look here this is the levels of the quit
rates and the levels by industry and
region if we go ahead and we zoom in on
it you can see that there are a ton of
insights on this the total private
industry in september of 2021 was 4.2
million people from around the world all
decided they were to quit their jobs
they out see you later now if we go
ahead and we look at this the trade
transportation and utilities industry
lost 984
people 984 000 people coming out of that
trade transportation and utilities we
then look at the professional and
business services they lost 706 000 and
then education and health services
651 000 and then lastly of course the
leisure and hospitality industry they've
been getting beat up non-stop no one can
save them
987 000 job losses in september or job
quits i'm sorry ain't nobody losing
their job they're quitting their job
they're out they'll see you you can't
fire them they quit
now there's a whole bunch of stuff that
you could read into this but before we
get to that number of unemployed persons
per job opening is falling that is a
good sign it's .7 today but it was
not so hot just a few months ago so that
is improving which is a good sign but
still we continue to see that the
unemployment rate is at 4.6 there are
10.4 million open jobs and 4.4 million
people in the month of september quit
their jobs and gave the middle finger to
their employer so we got two quotes here
the first quote coming from nick bunker
the economic research director at indeed
the rise of quitting across the labor
market is remarkable but the
concentration among a few sectors is eye
popping quits are up the most in sectors
where most work is in person or
relatively low paying you want to make
me go to the office people are quitting
you want to pay me not that much money
people are quitting doesn't take a
genius to try to figure this out then we
also have this quote from ben ires who's
a senior economist at nationwide who
said we do expect that higher
compensation and plentiful openings will
draw more workers to re-enter the labor
force in coming months hoping to ease
the tight labor market somewhat but as
the unemployment rate approaches
pre-coveted levels next year and is
expected to drop further beyond that the
labor market could remain relatively
tight throughout the current expansion
now here is my take on all of this all
this data is amazing but guess what
there's three things that people should
take away from this one is that
inflation is at over six percent people
quite literally are falling behind if
i'm going to work every day and i'm
falling behind i can't stay there i at
some point have to say i got to do
something different so they quit their
job and they go find either a different
job or they go try to figure something
else out so inflation drives massive
massive pain for people who cannot
continue to get raises that keep up with
the rate of inflation so for you at home
go ask your boss for a raise it's less
than six percent tell them you're not
even keeping up with the pace of
inflation let's go pick it up i need
more money the second thing that people
don't really talk about is that there's
lots of people who are quitting their
jobs and they're going in to new types
of jobs that you wouldn't necessarily
think of a job somebody quits their job
and starts a podcast and somebody quits
their job and literally goes on to
tick-tock or instagram or youtube and
they begin to make a living there is
that a new job well what if they quit
their job as a journalist at a
mainstream media organization and then
go and start a sub stack where they get
paid that is normally not considered a
traditional job and so there are all
kinds of new industries that are popping
up you can even look in the crypto space
what if i become a bitcoin miner am i
all of a sudden employed or not employed
how do i account for it there's lots of
complexity here so that is definitely
happening as well
and the third thing and probably the
most important thing is there's an
entire generation of people they don't
want to go into the office why do i need
to go sit in the office why do i got to
put on the suit and tie and go play the
game play the charade they don't want to
do it they understand that they can be
just as effective just as efficient and
just as productive sitting their asses
at home in a coffee shop or hanging out
with their friends they don't need to
work and do it 12 hours a day six seven
days a week and literally get pushed and
pushed and pushed until they completely
erode their quality of life instead they
say listen we have all this new
technology and i have the ability to sit
anywhere in the world whether i'm
sitting in the united states in a major
metropolitan or if i am going and living
somewhere in a rural area or if i want
to be somewhere international it
shouldn't matter as long as i get the
work done pay me and i'll see you when
you need me